this shocking video published on social
media shows leandro law being taken to
the hospital on sunday night the 33 year
old brazilian jiu jitsu legend had just
been shot in the head in a nightclub in
brazil's largest city sao paulo
referee museu gianchadis tells us
leandro was admired by fans and
adversaries alike because of his unique
style and carefree personality
[Applause]
we lost an icon
low had won eight international titles
one of them in the absolute division
which is regarded as the ultimate
proving ground in brazilian jiu jitsu
tournaments to see such a legend lose
his life in such a cowardly fashion it's
sad and revolting the crime shocked
brazilians and the international martial
arts community
on sunday after law was taken to the
hospital a crowd surrounded a nearby
police station demanding justice
authorities have detained military
police officer engio tavio oliveira
velozo for the crime he's being accused
of shooting the jiu jitsu champion in
the head after an altercation
although velozu was off duty he
reportedly took his gun to the club
police officers should not be allowed to
bring their weapons to nightclubs when
they are off duty they should leave it
at the door it's a place where people
are drinking and things can get out of
control
leandro law's killing also sparked
debate on social media about gun control
since president xi bolsonaro took office
almost four years ago brazilian gun laws
have been relaxed monica yanake of al
jazeera rio de janeiro